[Music]
all right guys
conspiracy corner time oh [ __ ] see baby
Corinne corner is it this way no this is
make a conspiracy corner no just turn it
or something
all right so if you've been on Twitter
you have heard of this conspiracy theory
around weight fair I'm not even on
Twitter and I'll [ __ ] seem to shin
it's connected to the next trafficking
pedophile center ring the wayfarer isn't
like the furniture furniture website
mm-hmm gonna if it's true the very sad
very sad Betty Betty sorry just sound
like Donald Trump when he said it's very
very sad really does be I didn't really
talk like a baby Bart he does very sad
every turn up oh come on that's not
laughing like I he does say crazy [ __ ]
but just I think my comedian side looks
out on my mask isolators you know what
blew my mind was his acceptance speech
when he won I thought he was gonna
blunder it cuz he didn't look like he
was gonna win like his face was like I
[ __ ] won remember that was it or was
it like they actually came through and
made me win I thought it was like holy
crap I like I didn't even expect to win
I thought Hillary was gonna win I liked
it when him and his team are like a
dressing like corona issues korabik he's
in the back and like foul here whoever
they're like talking in the front you
could see him just kind of go [ __ ] hurry
up god damn and they talked so [ __ ]
much was it my turn then just seeing him
in the back of so funny I like when
they're like they asking questions and
like a doctor someone like hey we're not
actually a lot of speak on that and he
comes I was like my favorite [ __ ] is
watching the people around him and their
facial reactions while he's speaking
yeah they're like they just crown like
cover this [ __ ] oh yeah there's that
lady that works from that like I think
she quit recently but she was like his
press secretary
yeah we're every time she quit too you
can go into press secretary yeah cuz
it's I get their jollies so every time
she goes online has to defend what he's
actually saying and then she's Lily just
like how do I twist this my cancer notes
and his notes yet to scratch out China
virus coronavirus yeah I don't [ __ ]
make a note for that Ellen talking about
Trump even though he might be connected
who knows that beacon a lot of people
could be connected Obama I reconnected
yeah everyone everyone that you know
that it's famous on in like traditional
Hollywood is probably compatible de 2.0
baby ok so what's up with this wayfarer
thing okay
so someone noticed that it was quite
interesting and just very very strange
that wayfarer had these storage cabinets
for sale and they like the name of the
cabinets are first names of like like
people names and these storage cabinets
go for like 14th out like fifteen
thousand for very expensive cabinets
yeah like there's no way these cabinets
are worth that much and then also if you
you can see by the photo that they all
look alike like there's no description
to even justify the actual amount that
they're charging for these cabinets so
someone went on reddit under like a
conspiracy reddit forum and dave we're
just talking about like hey isn't this
weird like it is what is this all about
and then from there it just spread on to
twitter and then they were saying that
the original post somehow got deleted
and like I'll be like it just made the
conspiracy theory even more crazier
especially because Wayfair ended up
taking those cabinets off the website
and people are like what the [ __ ] did we
actually stumble on some some real [ __ ]
because now they're covering their
tracks but wafer came out and said this
is their response they said there is of
course no truth to these claims
obviously they're gonna say that they're
gonna be like yeah we are [ __ ]
trafficking children anyway open up the
cabinet just keep to see a couple kids
inside yeah
well it's not even that ok well ok so
then they say the products in question
are industrial grade cabinets that are
accurately priced recognized
is double the price if you go to your
line you can get [ __ ] industrial
cabinets like $200 yep not 14,000 max 4
grand if it's like super industrial
heavy metal like crazy [ __ ] yeah so then
they said recognizing that the photos
the descriptions provided by a supplier
did not adequately explain the high
price point we have temporarily removed
the products from sight to rename them
and to provide a more in-depth
description and photos that I clearly
depict the product to clarify the price
point but before they came out with this
statement there were other people going
in there like journalists that are kind
of already immediately trying to debunk
debunk this without even like actually
getting out any further information but
they were saying that oh this is just
like a glitch in the system there's
probably they are probably pricing these
items so high up so then they don't have
to re-enter the product into the site
once it comes back on the market and
they're probably pricing this just to
deter people from actually purchasing
what about the names though the
coincidental names their unique - it's
not like Sarah yeah they're really
unique names so then people started
looking up missing children and a lot of
these children just so happen to have
the same names of these products on the
cabinets on the website and so a lot of
people that are already dismissing this
story I was like that's [ __ ]
ridiculous why would you why would they
be selling kids in cabinets why is it
like any one of us can just purchase it
and all of a sudden there's gonna be a
human showing up at our front door cause
ain't nobody dropping fifteen G's on a
cabinet that does that but then people
that are are for this conspiracy theory
they're saying like well obviously
you're not they're not gonna ship you a
kid right away after you you purchase
this that just gives that this probably
makes you go on to some sort of list
that then they can vet you out more and
see like oh are you are you worthy of
getting a [ __ ] kid I don't know but
not just that when people were searching
up the SKU numbers just ask you the SKU
number yeah and they would Google that
into Yandex which is a Russian web
search engine yeah it's a Russian search
search engine and when people are right
putting these numbers in and then they
put the s
our c-usa code which is connected to
some possible pedophilia ring like
keywords they're finding photos of young
children and like little like girls and
stuff but that part has been kind of
like debunked sort of where they're
saying that if you could just put any
random set of numbers and then put those
keywords in it's gonna show up all kids
because it's that keyword yeah eggs just
has a lot of weird like kind of
borderline child porn [ __ ] on there all
the time because I watched another
documentary of like how they a lot of
predators are just using that site for
that kind of purpose yeah it's for my
quick little research that I did there's
two ways this can go I'll tell you how
criminals can use this as a way for
checks sex trafficking and I'll tell you
the other evidence that I found where it
kind of debunked this right so the one
part is people are like so if I order
this cabinet or is a kid gonna pop out
like am I gonna get a shift and then
open it yeah it's like no obviously this
is what's happening in a criminal
enterprise right obviously you don't
want to deal with too much cash if this
is if a child is worth 10 grand each
right and you're constantly turning this
number out so let's say you sell you'll
sell 10 kids that's $100,000 cash how
are you gonna move that in to the system
meaning drug dealers have to figure out
a way to launder money and child sex
traffickers have to figure out a way to
launder money so the best way to do it
is you go on wayfarer you have a fake
business right and then you sell you're
a cabinet business yeah cuz wafer it's
kind of like Amazon it's like eBay
Amazon or Ebay right independent sellers
I didn't so like let's say you are a
[ __ ] you're in the market for a kid
you come into my notebook and and I show
you all right I have these I have this
name whoever which one you want all
right
I want this one all right well buy this
and I know your company let's say you
you purchase kids for your brothel or
whatever and you have a fake company
it's called
ninjas or whatever
ninjas LLC right and then so so you have
your fake [ __ ] company and then you
purchase as a write-off like business
supplies you need cabinets for your
business and then that's one sure way
where a lot of criminal enterprises they
use front businesses to do transactions
but they're not technically buying a
cabinet they're buying kids so I can see
how like people like this is ludicrous
it's like nah not so much if I want to
buy weed from someone like that's worth
like 20 50 grand worth right in one
transaction like how am I gonna do that
or cocaine or whatever like you gotta
turn that money and put you can't just
deposit hundreds of thousands of dollars
into your bank account and then use that
money to purchase homes and things like
that right so that's one way the other
thing is the top left corner that girl
was already found in 2017
there's several girls that are being
there like pictures are being used as
like the girls that are missing in
cabinets and they're coming out they're
like that's me in the photo [ __ ] are you
doing that right so there are some girls
that are actually missing and there's
some girls with the names that's just
coincidental and they're like you're
using my photo and I've never been went
missing and what but another thing to
point out is that like hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of kids go missing
like on the hour every hour yeah world
in this country and so they're just like
well yeah you're bound to have like a
coincidental name that matches the
cabinet to some kid that might be
missing you know what's eerie tho so
Wayfair just the wait phonetically when
they take it apart wave means missing
child and fair means what you pay to
transport I didn't see that one but you
know that's I so it's not spelled the
same way but wave is sound wave wave is
a missing child how do you spell that w
AI F so it's just like it's just it's
just eerie you know like that this is
[ __ ] areas
no this other one that makes me be like
how do you explain that one too is the
fact that Wayfarer employees back when
they were doing that I mean they're
still doing it the ice children center
like the detention centers they are
wayfarer was supplying furniture to
these centers wafer employees protested
against it they were literally like
protesting like we don't want wayfarer
to be involved in this
how is there that we find out the kids
are sleeping on the floor in cages but
they're supplying furniture and also
there are about 2,000 kids missing from
these from these centers centers oh [ __ ]
really I don't get it wait Faraday I
want to be involved in wasn't move so
wafer was involved in supplying like
detention centers in like Texas with
furniture cells be okay so J lead with
that and then wait for employees were
protesting it and they didn't want wait
for it be affiliated yeah yeah what
she's saying is that we missing children
from those centers I could have children
just boom missing yeah there's a there's
a link yeah people don't understand how
many kids go [ __ ] missing and
kidnapped like it's a lot dude and in
this next there's not enough milk
cartons and [ __ ] to put a face on this
next left on the oat milk and almond
milk tuna now Oh milks this other stuff
I saw on Twitter so I don't know how
like like for sure and concrete this is
but there were people pulling up and
looking into the background of wafer and
its CEO and the CEO has something Shaw
right sorry
but getting you right now oh [ __ ] okay
you got bad dry yeah it was like itching
my throat yeah okay
sorry so they were saying that the CEO
was looking into I mean that they have
some sort of relationship with
that chick and also if you look into who
owns like the board members away fare
and all this stuff apparently George
Soros is also somehow involved in this
and like I said I don't know how
accurate this is but a lot of people are
like just connecting a lot of dots that
were like what the [ __ ] this is just two
coins
yeah that's just crazy did you say
someone step down oh yeah I'm the CEO of
step down twelve hours ago
what I didn't see that way / CEO yes I
don't know that's [ __ ] weird I don't
know if it's just too much unnecessary
drama I can't stand social media yet so
it could be that I don't know first
headline says rumor debunked treat their
hoax wait for it oh wait no okay I saw
like three articles that said it yeah
yeah paddle gate 2.0 let's see what the
[ __ ] yeah I already say it it's like
it's like nah that's not child
trafficking I'm gonna resign though do
you resign and then it's just like like
those cabinets are worth 15,000 see you
guys later
yeah I mean the fact that wafer came out
and said does this is price accurately
we just took it down just so that you
could get more photos and more
descriptions dude Oh scary times better
so all these cabinets are just like
names like just actual like people's
names so then okay okay grand for a
[ __ ] cabinet I don't believe it but
they do tend to have because I shall
want to wait for all the time and there
are a lot of brands that actually do
name their their furniture pieces like
people names and not just some wayfarer
but I've seen this and like other
furniture sort like Pottery Barn or
whatever they they have so I'm just like
okay you can't just go based off of only
that you really have to connect all the
dots it's just weird that it's like the
same cabinet but with different names
and a little bit it's a mess the same
cabinet yeah and then but the other
thing that makes me actually further
into the conspiracy theory and making me
believe it is how hard traditional media
is trying to debunk it where it's like
you're not even taking all of these
like little like I guess they might be
facts I don't know for not facts I don't
know for a fact but like the little
things like like little things that
people are pointing out that you can see
like oh you can look into the ownership
of the company or whatever it is like
actual little facts that just end up
connecting just like pizza gate stuff
doing that so they can distract you from
what's actually wrong what's that well I
really love conspiracy theories right
but the way that they formulate it
basically it's like a magic trick right
like doing the way our minds work the
human brain like if you're not a step
dick and you don't understand how to
sort evidence correctly it's really easy
to believe this [ __ ] because of how its
set up so the way that most people can
kind of get tricked into just blindly
believing this is the same way that you
can meet someone through a gateway into
a cult well but I'm not saying that it's
wrong or it's right or it's real or not
we don't we just don't have enough
evidence to oh yeah I'm gonna read this
little thing where I saw this on Twitter
too and they're saying this the problem
with conspiracy theories is that there
is no set of facts no matter how solid
that can disprove them the conspiracy
theory that can always be adapted to
include new evidence against it that's
why it's a fool's game to try to counter
them it's also why conspiracy theories
all always grow more elaborate and
ridiculous over time people who buy into
conspiracy theories are falling victim
to a flaw in the human brain human
brains are amazing pattern matchers the
problem is that the brains pattern
matching logic is also really good at
fooling itself yeah spurious
coincidences become patterns that demand
a story to explain them the brain works
really hard to supply the story and once
sorry
and once one is found even if it's false
and the brain resists any evidence
against it it's really it's really an
unfortunate side effect of the evolution
of our brains amazing visual cortex and
said we all learn in stats that
correlation is not causation there might
be a connection there might be things
that's like oh what a coincidence but
then we still don't know if that's
what's actually happening unless we have
an underground I mean a
recover investigation and we actually
purchase a kid this way and we see the
whole link of everything and then you go
alright this is some [ __ ] I wish I
had enough money where I delight
investigate it test it out yeah and not
care if I lost like 15 G's just to see
what the next but I'm saying that even
if you pop by a cabinet like you it's
just gonna be a cabinet because think
about it right like you bet you out yeah
they have to figure out yeah maybe maybe
traditional media did do their research
and that's why they're sticking to it or
maybe they got paid out no they got paid
out for sure for sure I'll believe that
conspiracy more than I believe the
wayfarer conspiracy you know what I mean
the idea of media and who runs it and
for what reasons because maybe they
might not be covering child sex
trafficking but they are inadvertently
covering something else using that media
source so you know what I'm saying like
there's so many things so there have
been actual victims of sex trafficking
that have come out and like they spoken
out and again this is on Twitter I don't
know how true it is that's actually we
are that they actually are victims but I
did see this one thread of this one
person who said he was a victim saying
like you know my my dad trafficked me in
my city and like it's not that we're
being sold through wayfaring cabinets or
whatever like there's actual sex
trafficking happen happening in
neighborhoods and people are just so
blind to the actual like reality of it
so they're looking for crazy wild like
goose chase kind of stories were in your
house that's like sketchy down the road
and they're like last week they just
found a house where they basically like
someone called it in there was like all
the police came but then they were like
literally like hiding the kids hiding
all the adults putting them in badly
just took them away we don't let anyone
near then that's the last day out of it
like the police literally like hid the
kids as they why I get for their safety
too but didn't know what's wrong with it
yeah so then like actual victims are
really upset about this whole Wayfair
conspiracy because they're like stop
getting distracted like actually look at
well you're looking you're telling
people that don't understand crime like
they're just gonna go on a wild goose
chase like they don't know where to look
[Music]